take a look at brielle's last four years
at target field he's comfortable here he
does a great job here and i think he's
gonna have a good start today to follow
up that no hit county has had his last
time out ty france an infielder by trade
might get most of the dh duties for the
marylanders this year
swung on and missed
a blazing 96 mile per hour fastball to
now
almost right on cue
swings and misses but yeah this is just
like he's picking picking up right where
he left off picked up right where he
left off starting his season with seven
no hit in him cluckston nearly hit his
fourth home run yesterday against a
left-hander a line drive off the board
that hit the top of the wall in right
field
that is a fair ball down the line
garlic round second he'll go to third
boxton to second base and byron keeps
piling up not just hits
but extra base hits he's got
six extra base hits or six hits in six
straight games so it's incredible to see
what he's been able to do when he's been
in the lineup
france struck out on a one-two pitch
first time up
going to work
it will yeah he muscles it splits the
difference between the second baseman
and buxton coming around this terrence
ty france gets it done again merits have
a one-nothing lead rbi number four for
ty great plate coverage by this guy
there's garlic batting polanco leads off
second nobody out bottom three and the
1-0 pitch is swinging a fly ball left
field and deep back it goes deep it goes
and that falls in play and off the wall
polanco rounding third heading home
garlic to second a double polacco scores
all tied one to one real close to going
out of the ballpark got himself a little
hanging curveball up in the zone up and
away got extended and about halfway up
that long left field just like that we
got ourselves a tie ball
garlic at third bucks into first base
only one out garber hit the ball hardest
first time up but flied out the warning
track in center wow blasted to center
tramell going back it is tall on a
three-run blast for mitch carver
okay he's lost to the warning track his
first at-bat this time he didn't miss it
listen listen to that crowd how do you
respond when the other team scores first
which ones already have four runs on the
board straight away central a three-run
shot for the sauce
and the twins take a 4-1 lead nearly
went that way in the first
cleared the wall and found the juniper
plants and straight away center field
so garber goes deep and the twins have
four in and have taken a three-run lead
he set the bar awfully high that was as
good as i think anyone has ever seen him
and then he reminded us that he took a
no-hitter
call third strike locked him up with a
breaking ball one down
half swing strike three and rios has a
couple of
strikeouts pitching with a lead now
randy burriles delivers four got a miss
chased into dirt and jose three punch
outs as jose stands up to las diaz as he
departs
last he is barking back a little bit
adam three up three down three
strikeouts bottom of the fourth and
they're calling them off it started to
rain yeah it was supposed to be just a
passing shower and of course they all
are but they are going to pull the
mariners off the field
with coming down pretty hard now you can
see the
what we believe to be the initial stages
of removing the tarp is already underway
siger in his 11th season with america
who strikes again to seeger
just barely getting back this time is
haniger a much closer play
and the twins will take a look at it in
the video roll see this is such an
uncomfortable place to be as a runner
two outs two strikes you're going as
soon as you see that back coming through
you want to get a good jump and score
but
with this shift they're playing here oh
that might be i might take a look at
that i'm going to take a look at that
that's close
it's worth a look i think like baez
outstanding shortstop for the cubs and
how quick he can drop the tag i think we
just saw the same thing from simmons
yeah his glove work is incredible
obviously it's got gold on it's got
platinum on it for a reason
but this is one of those
as i was saying as a base runner you
know for so long
especially in the first part of my
career they were off your right shoulder
off your left shoulder and you knew
where they were at here you don't really
know where he is he's in a shift and
he's lined up almost directly behind
second you can't feel if he's creeping
in when he's straight up at short and
you're taking your lead you can feel if
he's off your right shoulder you can
kind of feel if he's off your left
shoulder but
when he's in the spot he's in line up
directly behind second base he can start
creeping in you can't really tell
you see simmons just three steps in and
he's right there he's got the bag
straddled and drops that tag on him
is that going to be enough to overturn
it i don't know after the seventh inning
you can ask the umpires for you know
another
look at it and
out of second base
it's a successful challenge nicely done
a couple of hits one runner left we're
going to the bottom of the fifth boston
double beat out a double play grounder
in the inning where the twins scored
their four runs
a high fly to left
hagerty back
no chance
buxton again with an extra base hit
he now has seven hits
three doubles and four home runs
i mean what can he say i mean this is
another no doubter as well i mean the
first three were
over 400 feet this one i'm guessing is
probably over 400 feet and you watch him
hold that finish
and he just knew as soon as it left his
back
enjoy that trot all that speed
jog around the bases that's a such a
good feeling and it's so good to see him
i would not throw that man a breaking
ball for a strike this is the guy you'd
like to see get going walked his first
time up his third look at marco gonzalez
see if he's able to make an adjustment
there's a ball whistled into the left
field corner
carver will score suno will hold up with
a single but a very sharply hit one and
a run batted in and you're patient with
him just for that reason right there
because at any point
he can square him all up and drive a run
in for you and does a nice job right
here gets himself a little 88 on the
inner part of the plate real simple
swing just takes the barrel to it and
that'll be the end of marco gonzalez's
day disappointing outing for gonzalez
in his debut mariners bringing a
right-hander drew stechenreiter
high and deep to the left field corner
sono setting up for a tag and he'll come
home
and arrive brings him in with a fly ball
a nice productive at-bat right there
drives in another run the league gets
more comfortable
marmot for two hit a hard hit
liner to right field
ending the third inning he won
high drive
and that looks like it will
leave the yard jose marmaleos
for the home run
it's his first of the season his third
run batted in
now 7-2
twins
armor gave it a good ride yeah he did
jumped on a breaking ball looked like a
hanger one of the few bad breaking balls
we've seen this afternoon
and he knew it as soon as he touched it
up
exit v low we'll give him 107.
424 feet up into the second deck
impressed 86 pitches for jose dillon
moore second base he's played in every
game this year for seattle
he messed with one fastball came back
with another got the corner and another
strikeout and that'll be the end of real
stay day
nice job
eight strikeouts in five and two-thirds
innings gave his team a chance to win
and real nice job just perfectly located
good as he was last year he was never
able to hear this
kepler smashed a line drive caught his
last time up
well there you go
there that's the one you were looking
for that's what i kept that selling
telling you just put it on the grass on
the left
take it any way you can get it and luisa
rise the only twin that is yet to reach
the ball lifted high and deep to right
center field back is haniger
and that's gone
but eyes hits his first home run of the
year
it looked like he was trying for his
first few at bats he took some big
swings maybe a little bigger than what
we're used to seeing for him with
this one perfect head down and just
tease off on it and this twins increase
their lead brandon waddell he made quite
an impression and got a lot of swings
and misses with a breaking pitch that
you'll probably see a few times here in
the ninth inning
one hop to polanco
a convincing win for the twins
a convincing first week
as the twins improve to five and two